[Music]
in chapter one of ursula k leguin's
sixth and final earth sea novel the
other wind alder has sought out ghetto
sparrow hawk the former arc mage on
gaunt and he's having terrible dreams in
which he is coming to the border land
between life and death in the earthsea
universe and he's told ged part of the
story and now the story gets more
complicated when ged asks him
tell me how it was when you came to rope
roak the isle where the high arts of
magic are taught roke the place that has
the imminent grove whose roots reach
down to the very bottom of the earth
broke the aisle of magic majory and
wisdom and so alder tells this story he
leaves the ship at the dock at thwill
town and the sailors draw the rune of
the closed door to prevent him ever from
coming back on board because they're
afraid of him and he's looking for
the you know the the great school there
and twill is kind of a weird town you
know he can see the school but he can
never quite get there finally he comes
to
a door and
he
recognized that the wall is the one that
he was trying to get to he knocks and a
man with a quiet face and quiet eyes
opens the door alder was ready to say
that he'd been sent by the wizard barrel
of a with a message for the master
summoner but he didn't have a chance to
speak the doorkeeper gazed at him for a
moment and said mildly you cannot bring
them into this house friend and that
tells a lot right there he calls him
friend but he says you can't bring them
with you who are the the you or the them
alder did not ask who it was he could
not bring he knew he'd slept scarcely
all the past nights
snatching fragments of sleep waking in
terror dozing off in the daylight
and waking the dream was in him with him
around him veiled and he could hear
always faintly through all the noises of
wind and sea
the voices that cried his name he did
not know now if he was awake or asleep
he was crazy with pain and fear and
weariness and he tells the doorkeeper
keep them out and let me in for petey's
sake let me in the doorkeeper does he
lets him in
and alder uh you know is is basically
entirely cashed out the summoner uh
appears and tries to hold a conversation
with alder and he's not really up to it
and what we find is that the summoner is
going to enter into
his dreams
all right the master summoner came alder
was not able to talk
and then as he remembered the sunlit
room was all together gone he was on the
gray hill but with him stood the
summoner of rogue a big broad
dark-skinned man with a great staff of
you wood that shimmered in the dark
place
the voices had ceased calling the people
the crowd and figures at the wall were
gone
he could hear a distant rustle and a
kind of sobbing as they went down into
the darkness
the summoner stepped to the wall and
here we find out something really
important he put his hands on the wall
the stones had been loosened here and
there a few
lay fallen on the dry grass alder felt
he should pick them up and replace them
mend the wall but he did not
the summoner says
who brought you here and alder says my
wife mev summoner here alder stood dumb
at last he opened his mouth but it was
not his wife's true name that he spoke
her use name instead lily
and then she doesn't come the summoner
summons her
with her name
and alder felt the breath go out of him
there was some movement something
lighter coming up the hill alders shook
with fear and yearning and whispered oh
my dear love
but it's not lily or maeve who's coming
instead it's a child of 12 or so
it paid no heed to him or the summoner
never looked across the wall but just
settled down under it when alder came
closer and looked he saw the child was
prying and pulling at the stones trying
to loosen one then another
the summoner tries to speak to the child
in the old speech
the child glanced up indifferently and
went on tugging at the stones with its
thin fingers that seemed to have no
strength in him this is so horrible to
alder his head spun he tried to turn
away and beyond that he could remember
nothing until he woke up in the sunny
room so this is the first you might say
guided attempt to make sense out of what
is happening to him the summoner of roke
one of the most powerful
magic users in the entire earth sea
universe
is not able to actually make any
progress with the child or in calling
lily
the next thing we see happening
is the door keeper is joined by the
master herbal and the master summoner
and
the herbal is able to
heal alder to some degree
he wakes up and the master herbal was
there with the tepid and sipid tea and
the earth smelling smoke the dull
unchewnful tant chant and and the touch
of his hand and alder could have rest
and on the fourth morning the three
masters the herbal the doorkeeper and
summoner came to his room
alder bowed to the summoner with dread
almost distrust in his heart
the herbal was a great mage but his art
was not altogether different from
alder's own craft of mending so that
they had a kind of understanding the
summoner though dealt with not with
bodily things but with the spirit with
the minds and wills of men with ghosts
with meanings his art was arcane
dangerous full of risk and threat
and he had stood beside alder there not
in the body on the boundary at the wall
with him the darkness and the fear
returned
the doorkeeper however is is a kind of
benign figure
and what do they do they explain things
to him they question him they deliberate
about what is to be
done
what we find out
is he tells
the summoner tells alder about the
nature of the wall and about
the previous summoner thorian who had
crossed the wall looking for ged and
lebanon and then was bid to come back
and came back but as he says
what came back was only his skill his
power his ambition the will to live that
gives no life
we trusted him because we had loved him
so he devoured us until eerie and
destroyed him
as they go on
he says the two masters had been silent
for a while after the herbal spoke about
thorian
alder got up the courage to ask him
about a matter that had been much on his
mind how those who came who died came to
the wall and how the mages came there
and the summoner says it's a spirit
journey the old healer says it's not in
the body we cross the wall if a mage
goes there and vision is sleeping body
is here we call what makes that journey
from the body the soul the spirit
and then
they they deliberate because alder says
but my wife took my hand i felt her
touch
the summoner says so it seemed to you
but the herbalist says if they touched
bodily a link was made
might that not be why the other dead can
come to him call to him even touch him
and the summoner says that is why he
must resist them
and alder says i try to resist them
there's so many of them and she's with
them and they're suffering crying out to
me the summoner says they cannot suffer
death ends all suffering and the herbal
says
maybe the shadow of pain is pain there
are mountains in that land and they are
called pain
so there's a very interesting
set of discussions is it not we have the
summoner saying this is all symbolic
this is all on the spiritual and the
herbal saying well
we got to be a bit more careful with
this maybe it's not quite so cut and
dried as you're saying summoner maybe
there's something more
going on with this
and the door keeper brings up another
consideration alder's a mender
not a breaker i don't think he can break
that link and the summoner says if he
made it he can break it again you know
the logic of this stuff and then the
question is did he make it and alder
says i don't have any such art and so
the summoner says then i must go down
among them and the door keeper says no
my friend and the old herbal said you
last of all so they decide
alder will be their guide and they will
all three of them go with him
to this
land they go there and there's this
really interesting description
the others were with him the herbal a
warm presence and the chill the door
keeper elusive and silvery as starlight
and the massive summoner a bear
dark strength
they go to the to the
the wall and hara the summoner's deep
voice called him back like a noose
around his neck a jerked leash he
staggered stumbled forward one step more
almost at the wall dropped to his knees
and reached out to the stone he was
crying save me but to whom to the mages
or to the shadows on the wall then hands
were on his shoulders living hands
strong and warm and he was in his room
and there were four men in the room with
him
not three
the fourth man
is as he says a far northerner
his eyes were the color of ice his hair
and skin were white
and this this man says to the mages what
are you doing my friends
and the herbal says taking risks of
ozvar trouble at the border patterner
said this summoner and the patterner
says
let him come to me he'll be safe in the
grove he won't be bothered
by all these things
there and so he goes to the grove and
there he's actually able to sleep
without having
these dreams
and he says
as soon as i came there i knew i could
sleep i felt as if i'd been asleep all
along in an evil dream and now here i
was truly awake so i could truly sleep
i slept and i cannot tell you the
sweetness of it
then interestingly enough what do we
find the patterner
actually tells him
you should go
and talk to sparrowhawk the archmage the
former arc mage the one that we know as
ged why because
he has the most experience with this
wall in the land of the dead i mean he
spent a lot of time there compared to
the rest of us so he seeks out ged in
god
and gad himself although he's no longer
like a member of the the council of the
wise at rock
he's got some very interesting things to
say
here's what he says
when i lived on rogue
i might have seen things as the summoner
does there i knew no power stronger than
what we call magery not even the old
powers of the earth
but
if the summoner is the man that i think
he came as a boy to rock my old friend
vetch of ifish sent him to study with us
and he never left that's the difference
between him and osver the patterner
osborne lived till he was grown as a
warrior's son
a warrior himself among men and women in
the thick of life matters the walls of
the school keep out he knows in his
flesh and blood he knows what what is so
important what has been left out
that men and women love make love marry
having lived these 15 years outside the
walls i inclined to think ozer might be
on the better track the bond between you
and your wife is stronger
than the division between life and death
and then alder says i've thought it
might be so but it seems it seems
shameless to think it prideful right we
loved each other more than i can say we
loved each other but was our love
greater than any other before us was it
greater than morid and alpharon's these
legendary
lovers from way back in the
tales of earth see
alpharon who ged himself summoned as a
spirit of the dead and looked upon for a
brief moment
here's where ged says something
really quite
interesting
he says well
sometimes there's a passion that comes
in its springtime to ill-fated death and
because it ends in its beauty it's what
the harpers sing of and the poets make
stories of the love that escapes the
years that was the love of the young
king in elfiran that was your love hara
and here's where it gets
very insightful it wasn't greater than
morid's
but was he is greater than yours
there's no less or greater
in an absolute thing all or nothing at
all the true lover says and that's the
truth of it my love will never die he
says he claims eternity and rightly how
can it die when it's life itself what do
we know of eternity but the glimpse we
get of it when we enter into that bond
love
in some respects is greater than life
itself and greater than the division
between life
and death
he goes on and says
every farm boy sings that every young
girl dr that dreams of love knows it
but it's not a thing that the masters of
rock are familiar with
the patterner maybe knew it early
i knew it late god is talking about his
own love with tenor over this this time
very late not quite too late
you had that
alder says i did
and then he says maybe they're there
together in the dark land morid and
alpharon
and sparrowhack says no
there are no lovers there
and here we come to the other great
insight that ged shares
he tells
alder that some great changes have come
because
you know in in the land of the dead
lovers pass each other by
but his wife came to him
called his name and kissed his mouth and
he says and since your love wasn't
greater than any other mortal love and
since you and she aren't mighty wizards
whose power might change the laws of
life and death
something else is in this something is
happening is changing though it happens
to you
and to you
through you and to you you are its
instrument and not its cause
so he goes on and he says
when my master i held died my wife was
here with him and as he was dying he
said to her it has changed all changed
he was looking across that wall from
which side i do not know and since that
time there have indeed been changes a
king on morid's throne no archmage of
rogue more than that i saw a child
summon the dragon collecting the eldest
and coalescing came to her
calling her daughter as i do what does
that mean
what does it mean that dragons have been
seen above the islands of the west
so there's great changes going on and
these dreams signify
more
than what they're being taken as just
this threat which is how the
masters of rock are interpreting it so
there's a lot going on here and
the most you might say insightful wise
people of the realm are trying to
make sense out of what is going on
through
this man alder
you